oh
bon
quel est le nom de votre compagnon je
vous présente va look wallon que le
magnifique c'est son vrai nom c'est un
chien qu'on m'a donné pour me remercier
c'est la télévision que la vienne qui va
donner ce chien pour me remercier
d'avoir été au canada pour pour une
interview et quand je les ai vus quand
ils sont allés avec le chien jeudi mais
je veux pas de chien moi je voulais plus
chiens deux pays depuis la mort de mon
boulot que j'ai je voulais plus de
chiens pions en même temps je le voyais
choyer ses yeux bleus extraordinaire
mais surtout c'était exactement moulouk
petit ou d'accepter ces cités comme ce
chien sauf qu'il n'avait pas les yeux
bleus et alors je me suis dit c'est
peut-être le bon dieu qui m'envoient
comme j'ai pas eu boulots petits puisque
je l'avais trouvée à la guerre alors je
me suis dit c'est peut-être le bon dieu
qui m'envoient le chien petit c'est
peut-être une réincarnation de mouloud
ne s'est pas une règle incarnation du
tout et pas du tout comme comme boulot
pour lui que c'était un chien
exceptionnel tout le monde dise à son
chien mais c'était vrai c'est vrai tout
le monde était d'accord là-dessus buluk
était un chef j'avais trouvé à la guerre
en 1939 et qui était attaché à un arbre
forêt de compiègne et des tessons
derrière acide et aurait droite les
races est féroce
alors j'ai eu un coup de foudre r je me
suis approché denis je vais détachées et
je ne veux plus jamais réate h et de sa
vie
je ne suis pas superstitieux mais la
chance a commencé à arriver avec mon
look
parce que au fond ce qui m'a fait partir
dans ce métier c'est le film l'éternel
retour
eh bien j'ai dû mon succès à l'éternel
retour pour deux choses pour un polo
vert et pour mon chien
ces deux choses ont fait que j'ai eu un
énorme succès et toute ma vie j'ai eu
l'impression que mouloud me protéger
j'avais l'impression que c'était un ange
gardien déguisé en chien
mon look été pris d'une passion pour moi
comme moi pour lui quand j'en côtoie
écrit l'éternel retour pour le chien et
moi il disait en riant bien sûr disait
qu tristan et zulte s'est pas madeleine
sologne et jean marais ses moules hockey
et ce chien était extraordinaire pour
del metro tous lille il a lu au
rendez-vous il quand il ne tournait pas
quand il était pas acteur dans le film
il était toujours derrière la caméra on
disait coupée
il se précipitait sur moi même si
j'étais elle sera alimentée sur le
cheval moulouk et eva look
ce sont des chiens de traîneaux de
l'alaska et naturellement ils détestent
la chaleur et même que le froid
je les ai vus ils dormir une nuit
entière dans la neige
paris nantes et bien moulouk détestant
la chaleur chez les férus de choses
extraordinaires pendant la guerre il
savait que j'avais froid et sentais que
j'avais froid
j'avais un sac de couchage que il vanne
de brême avait envoyé et bien buluk se
mettait dans devine n se mettait dans le
sac de couchage pour me réchauffer c'est
des choses incroyables et fantastique
dont celui là est un chien très
indépendant assez goris que pendant que
lui alors c'est pas lui qui se
coucherait près de moi pour moi chauffer
près pas du tout c'était une histoire
d'amour c'était une grande histoire
d'amour
mouloungui était était archi connus on
le reconnaissait même la nuit
j'entendais des gens qui disaient c'est
moulouk tout le monde le connaissait un
jour par exemple je me suis engagé dans
la division leclerc à paris après la
libération de paris et bon j'ai emmené
gérant de nîmes hulu pour gt5 soldats
mais je me suis arrangée avec d autres
soldats j'ai pas demandé à des officiers
j'ai demandé à des soldats si on pouvait
amener mon chien naturellement quand je
leur présentais le chien ils sont tous
tombés amoureux du chien de mendiants
mais l'on mène le bon et je suis parti
de paris avec la division leclerc et
j'étais sur un dodge décapoté il y avait
il y avait toute la foule qui regardait
sur les trottoirs la division leclerc
passé et tout d'un coup
moi j'étais invisible puisque j'étais
habillé en soldat parmi d'autres soldats
j'étais complètement visible et il y
avait mon look à côté de moi et j'ai
entendu des gens dire nés mais mais mais
c'est mon look mais chez le chien de
jean marais mais c'est jean marais et
les gens se sont précipités sur moi et
moi faire des gâteaux mon faire des
apéritifs en faire toutes sortes de
choses et mes camarades qui me
connaissaient pas parce que venus
d'afrique et j'ai dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce gars-là rive il est nouveau
dans la division nous on a on a délivré
paris et c'est à lui qu'on fait on fait
la fête et c'est pas c'est pas normal
alors ils ont posé les questions leur ai
dit alors expliqué que j'étais acteur et
que mon chien aussi et des acteurs
il est tombé malade le jour de la mort
de marcel cerdan et j'ai été affolés ils
avaient des espèces de râles
c'était près du théâtre théâtre de la
madeleine où je jouais chéri et je me
suis mis à pleurer j'ai appelé le
vétérinaire je me suis mis à pleurer
mais jaillon de pleurer et au restaurant
à côté du sien et j'attendais le
vétérinaire là et alors ils m'ont
directeur de théâtre a appris que
j'étais assez minable il est venu me
voir en me disant je ne savais pas que
tu avais tant de l'affection pour marcel
cerdan
alors j'ai encore eu plus honte j'ai dit
écoutez je m'explique c'est pas pour
marcel cerdan que je pleure c'est pour
bush look et après pendant deux ans je
me baladais avec des seringues du seul
quand vont ils tomber en syncope dans la
rue et je faisais une piqûre et ainsi
j'ai pu le garder encore deux ans grâce
aux piqûres
quand il est mort j'ai pas pu ré du tout
par contre mais je pouvais pas dire que
moulouk était mort je peux pas le dire
je peux pas sortir de ma bouche et ce
jour là jean cocteau déjeuner avec moi
et je lui ai pas dit que vous nous
traitez moi et huit jours après il me
revenait déjeuner et il me demandait une
meule de moules ou que je lui dis les
morts
la dernière fois que tu es du pays mais
comment comment tu comment est ce que tu
as pu ne pas me le dit jenny s'avouer
pas sortir de ma bouche je les cache à
tout le monde parce que je me suis dit
les journaux les radios tout le monde va
m'interviewer sur la mort de moulleau
que je vais être ridicule parce que je
vais dans la situation de de quelqu'un
qui a perdu un enfant et et je trouve ça
un peu
grotesque si vous voulez j'ai préféré me
taire
alors je les cacher
hautmont